[Music]
if you were the most overpowered being
on the entire planet what would you do
would you relish in that power making
the world recognize you for the
masterpiece that you are or would you
prefer to live a regular life as an
ordinary joke let your powers out only
when the situation calls for it
whichever camp that you're in let me
know down in the comments section below
well the title is already a spoiler for
this one isn't it but we're going to be
taking a look at what i think are the
top shows that deal with the latter
flexors have their appeal and i
absolutely love seeing someone like
arnos demolish some poor slob but i find
a tiny bit more appeal in the secret op
characters imagine someone thinking
you're just an ordinary guy only to get
a first hand taste of your power now
wouldn't that be a fun turnaround
[Music]
it may not be as big now but my whole
goal was quite the hit like novel back
in its day that's to say a little over
half a decade ago back when i was at my
peak in terms of consuming anime it's no
secret that the show has a place in my
heart and a lot of that has to do with
how sleek and cool the world looks i
just dig the setting so much with how it
intertwines magic and science in a more
elaborate way than what we're used to
getting in these urban fantasies for
others however the appeal lies in the
sheer satisfaction of our protagonist
constantly getting underestimated and
showing everyone what he's made of after
all he may be classified as a lower tier
student in terms of only one specific
area but in terms of everything else
there's little that god tsuya can't do
with the protagonist being the
equivalent of a military super weapon a
genius engineer a lethal battler and a
master analyst we could all agree that
the god suya nickname is more than
deserved dare touch miyuki and say
goodbye as they say
next we have king's avatar
back in the days when people talked
about mahoka somewhere down the line
there'd be a mention of sao the two have
been heavily promoted together since
they're under the same publishing label
both star and introverted op guy they
have the same pseudo-harem element and
they both are polarizing to say the
least major and sao second seasons even
aired at the same time period which
brings me to a title about video games
enter king's avatar a story of the
greatest glory players fall from grace
and road towards triumph well we've got
a lot of shows about video games and
i'll not really put as much focus on the
actual esports and out of game aspects
of it something which i think gave kings
avatar its major niche in the scene
where else would you find an anime that
gives you so much insight on the
business or political side of being an
esports player it was an unexpected hit
that took a while to pick up with the
fans but yishu's journey starting from
having everything taken away from him
and ending with him championing a new
legacy with his new account had me
constantly on the edge of my seat if
you're up for an esports story that puts
in great focus on the drama outside the
actual game then king's avatar may be
the one for you
[Music]
king's avatar isn't a pushover in terms
of cool fights but you would think that
if you put it side by side with our next
entry mob psycho
ah mob psycho popular creator ones work
which gets lauded for its breathtaking
animation and fight direction it wasn't
a surprise that mob psycho became such a
big hit when i watched it i was just
taken aback how could you not be with a
show that's this exciting especially in
a genre that i'm very fond of well mob
himself may not like how much i just
talked up about his show socially
awkward and incapable of reading the
atmosphere morph whose real name is
shigi okagayama has a lack of friends
and that doesn't really bother him it's
better that way especially given his
amazing powers that are tied to his
emotions bullies really beware mob may
not look it but push him and you'll live
your life regretting it overall the
animations are the main attraction of
mob psycho but i also love the series so
much with intricate character writing
the dynamics and the character
development parts are so top-notch that
i find it quite unfortunate that they
actually get overshadowed by the people
who can't stop talking about the
animation
oh and if you're enjoying the show so
far don't forget to leave a like hit
that subscribe button and ring that bell
it helps with the youtube algorithm so
much and it will motivate me to keep
making more and more videos for everyone
now i don't want to hold you up any
longer so let's get back to the show
ah talking about this show just takes me
back it took no less than an episode for
god of high school to wow the world with
its animation fluid fights and premise
that quickly hooked people in fighting
tournament anime aren't rare but there's
something so appealing about the way god
of high school went about it i don't
know if barky is the most proper
comparison to this but it just has that
atmosphere to how over the top the
fights become with tournament
participants coming in literally all
shapes and sizes it's a battle royale
for the ages and while i won't say this
is my favorite webtoon adaptation among
the ones 2020 gave us it's one hell of
an adrenaline booster god of high score
may have its shortcomings in terms of
pacing and decisions that the anime team
took but it sure never gets dull when
the fighting starts
coming up next is probably one of the
most popular mecca animes of all time
code geass
wait code geass yeah i get that surprise
reaction for such a spectacular and
charismatic character you wouldn't
really expect lelouch to be one of these
people most images you'd find of him
have him looking so full of swag and
he's known to be a master chess master
amongst chess masters in the world of
anime well he never started out that way
and that's after his development a long
road where he actually learns to drop
the stoic facade and become more
emotional heroic and extreme in his ways
which is just one of the things to show
what a ride code geass was especially
for those following it in the late 2000s
combining the cool appeal of mecca anime
in its tension-filled fights with more
mature content like politics morals and
psychology code geass managed to
catapult itself to the upper echelons of
critically acclaimed anime it was such a
phenomenon that the franchise still gets
new content to this day and when it does
expect the internet the older sector of
it to blow up in hype code geass is
really a show that you just have to see
its recognition is more than well
deserved and i wouldn't do it justice
just by talking about it like this
we've not seen the last of one's
footprint in this list with mob psycho
oh no no no no not when the next entry
is 2015's phenomenon one punch man
[Music]
the meme face says it all if you're
someone in the one punch man universe
the last thing you'd expect out of the
listless baldi is to be able to utterly
decimate you in one punch who knew that
the strongest hero amongst all those
called appearances was the simpleton but
that's exactly what makes one punch man
so fun it's an action show that's also a
parody of the whole shonen and superhero
genre it's got a lot of big moments and
scenes that makes your jaw drop plus the
heart-pounding battles that you'll just
keep on talking about for days on end
besides that i just like how one punch
man handles its balance yeah it's a
fast-paced action show that presents
itself as something you shouldn't take
too seriously but how can you do that
when it suddenly rains you with feels
like movement riders whole shtick when
that soundtrack comes in and all of a
sudden you feel like you're watching a
completely different show i think that's
what makes one punch man such a lovable
show it pulls you in with the crazy
stuff wrapped in a fake underdog story
from some angles before hitting you hard
with emotion and drama you can't help
but just get caught in
let's not stop with one chinese anime
and go to the next one with full-time
magister
[Music]
full-time managed is quite an
interesting title it's a 2016 show that
has a lot of elements including an art
style that feel like they're very
inspired from japanese media from a
decade ago you've got a world
intertwined with magic the magic skulls
and the cool edgy protagonist not quite
as edgy as the ones in revenge fiction
but now with sizeable rough edges to
give him that badass feel unfortunately
more key info would need some reading to
do because the actual show starts with
little introduction about the world not
that it detracts from the experience
because you're also focused on following
the story of our hero an aspiring
magician who looks to prove the world
wrong despite everyone mocking him about
poverty and his lack of magical ability
mo fan actually gains access to the fire
and lightning elements how's that for a
two-pronged attack against the world
that dared to look down on him does that
remind you of mahoka yeah it does
doesn't it if you like one you'll
definitely like the other since they
share so many elements the cool thing
about full-time magister is that you
have a lot of seasons to go through so
if you're up to the task of following
the rise of the nation's greatest
magician and you've got the time make
sure to try out this show
we've finished the chinese anime train
with daily life of immortal king
defeating a demon lord at a young age
grants you immense power so great that
wang ling now reincarnated in the
present faces his greatest challenge
senior high school talk about arnold's
volde goat vibes and like arnos though
wang ling decides to tuck his powers
away and live a life as a carefree
teenager that's all he wants to do none
of the supernatural craziness none of
that world ending magic instead he just
wants to be a plain old high schooler of
course that's going to be one insane
challenge because you just can't outrun
the forces beyond and one wrong move and
it's the end of the world as we know it
finally he still ends up flexing on
others subconsciously and comedy ensues
the show may not be a japanese anime but
takes a lot of elements from popular
titles including one that we are going
to get to shortly combining comedy with
flashes of action daily life of immortal
king is a show that a lot can like you
should try the first few episodes to see
if it's your taste but i think that it's
a nice light show to enjoy
[Music]
psychic powers are a blessing right
apparently not if you're so psyche who
wants nothing more than to have an
ordinary life free of the supernatural
inconveniences however with powers as
strong as his that's a lot easier said
than dumb especially if various animated
personalities want nothing more than to
hound you thanks to the abilities
psyche's life is indeed nothing short of
disastrous and fun to watch for the
viewers though this series of shorts has
been a fan favorite among anime fans it
also didn't take too long for me to be
caught up in the wave and it's a show
that i'm glad i picked up the episodes
are very easy to watch and come up with
all sorts of creative circumstances to
be used for creativity ashore can also
feel psyches pain as the world just
won't leave him alone whether you're
someone who likes comedy anime or not i
can easily recommend this one for you
with five minutes per episode the 200
episode count is not as daunting as it
may seem it's a really good way to pass
the time with some magical craziness the
whole cast of weirdos will keep you in
stitches and if they don't do it you in
the scenarios the fourth war break
surely will
and there you have it those are my top
picks for shows where the main
protagonist is hidden op which one
amongst those is your favorite let me
know down in the comments section below
now if you think you're up for more this
sort of thing then please check the
channel for more countdown videos the
channel mostly caters to shonen and
psychological suspense fans but there's
also content about romance and drama
titles support would also be much
appreciated as well and that can be
either in the form of channel
memberships my patreon or instagram
let's help each other grow those
communities right it's been a pleasure
and i hope to see you next time
videotube here saying farewell for now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]